with the brothers after after the
most of us have seen it. Allah
starting tomorrow I will be joining the
officially and so the idea is that we
sit down and we collectively take
turns reading until we get through an
entire J of the Quran. So that's 20
pages with light corrections and
you know and then if there's any
questions or any discussion after that
on any of the verses we can have that
[Arabic recitation]
A third and final announcement is
actually we would cordially ask that
starting immediately
that when we come in I know for probably
you know
ever since whenever
we've always used the side door to
come in. However, if you've noticed
during the past week, we've opened up
the main doors here for Isha. So,
there's a couple of reasons for that,
but we want to start using the main
door when we come in, put our shoes
there, put everything there, and then if
someone needs to use the restrooms, they
can cross across.
for a couple of reasons, but one
of those is so that the sisters as well
can have their own entrance to enter
from and they don't feel pressured
so that they can put their shoes on
the rack there and and have a you know
their own entrance inshallah. But that's
only going to work if we actually start
using it. So by sheer habit I see that
you know most of us are still using the
old way which is you know fine perfectly
fine but look at this big beautiful
giant door here it is so enticing so
inviting as you walk by it's beckoning
you to use it. So please for the
brothers use this new big door. It's not
new but it's new to us. So
any other announcements? You sure? Okay.
[Arabic recitation]
so sad about that. I really am. You
know, but we have words to exchange over
that. Inshallah.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing where we left off in
the verses of surah mud, we're here on
the last final around 10 verses of
surah mud. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says,
[Silence]
These are verses
32-37.
This is a portion of the Quran that is
known as
[Silence]
for
subhanahua.
[Silence]
woman.
, woman
[Silence]
this this part here is what we call the
of the Quran. What is the it is when
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala swears by
something when he says I swear by
right I swear by the morning sun
and the night when it wraps itself
around and becomes very still and in its
darkest
etc. These are two examples of many many
many places in the Quran in which Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala uses this type of
rhetoric which is referred to as
which is referred to as swearing by
something. Now these
things that Allah swears by they are
not obviously they are not random.
These things are not haphazard.
These things are strategically placed in
a chapter. They carry a particular tone,
a very particular meaning and sometimes
even a very particular rhythm that will
match and escalate
what is being said throughout the
chapter. Here Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
has just concluded the verse speaking
about the 19 angels that are the
gatekeepers of the hellfire. Malik and
his 18 subordinates and their
subordinates below them. He spoke
subhanahu wa ta'ala about the reasons
that he mentioned
these things and these details in the
Quran. And now he goes into
he says after this
word is usually used in the Quran to
negate whatever came before it. So
someone will say something that is
wrong. Allah will rebuttal and say kala
meaning this is incorrect but it doesn't
always mean that sometimes the word
keela is used as a means to draw the
attention of the listener to what is to
follow it meaning what is to follow it
is very important
subhanahu wa'ta'ala then says
I swear by the moon
and I further swear by the night as it
recedes.
Now
here Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is giving
us very specific imagery in our mind's
eye. He's swearing by the moon. He's
swearing by the night as it retreats.
And I further swear by the dawn as it
grows in intensity.
So what is the imagery here? What are we
collecting from this? I swear by the
moon. And I swear the moon usually
presents itself high in the sky and
becomes prominent towards the middle or
the second and final half of the night.
And the night begins to retreat when the
moon is in its fullest position in the
sky. And then the night further retreats
and recedes when the dawn starts to
break and intensify.
This is a parable for what? This is an
example and a parable for the coming of
the messenger, the arrival of the
messenger. People were in jeileia.
People were in a state of
misunderstanding, of misguidance. People
were in a state of worship of other than
Allah, idolatry, superstition,
indecency,
bloodshed, misguidance, confusion.
People were in a state where they
disbelieved in the last day. And here
Allah has appointed a messenger amongst
them. And now the moon has grown in its
intensity. the light of the moon, the
night has no choice but to recede and
retreat. And then the dawn breaks which
is a parable for the sending of jirel
with the verses of the Quran. The book
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is just
the daybreak as it comes to do away
with the night to do away with the
confusion,
do away with the guilt, do away with the
hopelessness.
People were suffering from incredible
hopelessness
before the Quran. And the Quran came
back came to restore people and restore
their hope in Allah and restore their
hope in their actual potential. And so
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala swears by the
moon. He swears by the receding and
retreating night. He swears by the dawn
as it grows in intensity.
What is
he says?
[Silence]
Monkeys.
for
[Silence]
And so Allah Subhanahu Waaala now comes
with the response, what is he swearing
by here? He swears by the moon and I
swear by I further swear by the night as
it retreats and I further compound that
swear by swearing by the morning sun as
it intensifies
and as it intensifies.
Indeed, this in this knowledge
and this revelation of suffer of the
hellfire and its descriptions is one of
the greatest
deterrents
and one of the greatest
warnings to mankind.
in.
And so he says indeed that hellfire that
was just described in the previous
verses, it is one of the greatest and
most grave of warnings.
Now, that imagery fits perfectly
because
people, they don't change. Human
beings, we naturally fear change. It
makes us feel we're not in control.
We can't predict what's going to happen.
And so, people are naturally adverse to
change.
However, this change,
this change of the prophet Muhammad
sallall.aii wasallam, this change of
jahyah, this change of the Quran,
it's a big change and it's painful at
times. However, it is the best of
change. It is necessary change. It is
just as necessary and just as beautiful
and just as grand and illustrious as the
morning sun breaking the dawn, as the
night retreating with its coldness and
with its stillness and with its
lifelessness and the moon being
outshined
by the sun. We got used to things in
night. We got used to things and we
started merely surviving. But the Quran
came to teach us how to live. Not just
to exist, not just to survive, but how
to live with hearts filled with hope and
reliance upon Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And so this change may be fought
against, but it is change for the
better. Second of all, this change is
inevitable.
It is just as inevitable as the sun
rising.
It is not something you can stop, oh
people of Quraysh, those who have chosen
amongst you to fight the message and
fight against the messenger and try to
hinder the path of Allah. Your fight is
as fruitless as it is in trying to stop
the sun from rising at morning. It's
impossible. It is inevitable. It is not
just a force of nature. It is beyond
that. It is the will of almighty Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. And so if you
choose to embrace it, you will lust
bluster in the sun. And if you choose to
fight against it, your fight is just as
hopeless as the night's fight against
the morning sun.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.